so winsome sears
who
who just became the lieutenant governor
of virginia
she was running along with glenn juncken
winsome sears
a black woman herself just went on cnn
and
and encountered the line that we're all
encountering about critical race theory
this is the official party line of cnn
namely
critical race theory
is not being taught in schools and she
says that's bunk
you oppose critical race theory being
taught in schools which i should say is
not part of virginia's curriculum
you did say though that the good and the
bad of american history should be taught
and
uh that we should also tell viewers
you're the former vice president of the
virginia board of education so explain
how you think race should be taught
in virginia public schools well let me
back up
i beg to differ that crt is not taught i
didn't say that i just said it's not in
the curriculum just to be clear
it no no no no it is part of the
curriculum it's weaved in and out of the
curriculum in fact in 2015 former
governor who was just defeated mcauliffe
his state board of education had
information on how to teach it so it's
weaved in so you know it's semantics but
it's weaved in
so love this she won't let cnn get away
with this cnn says beep boop beep beep
boop no critical race theory in schools
in virginia schools
i'm a talking head on cnn and then
the person they're talking to is the
former vice president of the virginia
school board so she says actually
uh cnn lady you have no idea what you're
talking about and i worked in this very
closely and
absolutely critical race theories being
taught in virginia schools and we just
won an election because of that
and then the cnn lady is smart enough to
know that she's not going to be able to
win the point she's not going to be able
to refute that fact with winsome sears
so she says well no no
i didn't say it's not being taught
i said
it's not in the curriculum
which is
a distinction without a difference
even the point the
side point she's trying to make even the
retreating point she's trying to make is
not true since 2015 over 100 000
independent farms and ranches in the us
have shut down why because foreign meat
is stealing their business and robbing
you of the quality and flavor that you
deserve that is why good ranchers is
here they exist to support local
american farms and help you make great
american meals together they want to
restore the american ranch and your
meals to their former glory get the beef
chicken and seafood that can't be
imported or managed at goodranchers.com
good ranchers is here to put america
first at the dinner table and the
farmers that worked to raise the meat we
eat really really great stuff i
especially love their burgers
all their stuff is terrific but me
they're burgers they're so juicy they're
so american i just love them go to
slash knowles goodranchers.com les right
now get 10 free bistro fillets and in
addition if you subscribe you will save
25 off of each subscription box of
mouth-watering american meats for
life these boxes will show up on
schedule right to your door so you get
10 free bistro fillets that's a 100
value free express shipping and 25 off
your monthly subscription for live at
goodranchers.com knowles that's
goodrangers.com code knowles at checkout
10 free bistro filets 25 bucks off your
monthly subscription for life
goodranchers.com
knowles the curriculum is
the schedule of things that are taught
if something is taught
it is in the curriculum
well no it's just some one random
teacher saying something that's what the
left might they say no it's just some
teacher going off script no it's not
it's being taught as a part of the
program
it is in the curriculum which is what
winsome sears is saying and
the way the left tries to get away with
this line is they say well there's no
unit of critical race theory it's not as
though students are taught okay now
we're going to learn about the american
revolution and now we're going to learn
about you know the enlightenment and now
we're going to learn about critical race
theory and now we're going to learn
about calculus right it's not
that's not how it's taught but that's
not what critical race theory is
critical race theory isn't a specific
academic
it is a movement it's not a specific
academic field
or a
unit
it is a an analytical framework
so it's it's not taught as just one
thing critical race theory is a lens
through which you view all the other
things
so no you're not going to spend two
weeks learning critical race theory
you're going to spend
a whole school year learning critical
race theory as it pertains to history as
it pertains to literature as it pertains
to economics as it pertains to
everything and that's what winsome sears
has to say
it's much worse don't let them tell you
that there's no lesson on critical race
theory in schools it's much worse than
that it's in all of the lessons
critical race theory says that
everything about america is hopelessly
rotten because
it is all
formed by white supremacy
and so everything about america the
culture the tastes the history the
military movements the
form of government the form of economics
it's all
hopelessly irredeemably
rotten because of white supremacy and
it's all going to be ripped out
by the root
and
beyond that what if if you can get the
left to admit that critical race theory
does play some role in the education as
that cnn ladies started to have to admit
the next thing that i'll tell you is
that you as a parent have no right to
stop it i'm glad you liked that clip
ring that bell ring it right now don't
hold at
ring that bell subscribe also if you
want to get the full show you know
without the censorship of certain
certain big tech oligarchs that i won't
name
uh head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your audio podcast type in the michael
knowles show subscribe leave a five star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]